this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace
if you're watching this Channel and it's
safe to say that you are then there's a
high chance that you're interested in
building muscle and increasing strength
but do you even know how to build muscle
and increase strength as in you might
know what to do in the gym but do you
know what's actually going on inside
your body in a response to training you
might think that you do a lot of people
simplify this down to Mechanical tension
metabolic stress and muscle damage but
it's actually a whole lot more
complicated than that there's a lot more
that often doesn't get explained and
there's a whole lot more that we don't
even understand that said we do know
enough to make a more optimal approach
to our training and this is one of those
scenarios where knowledge really is
power so without further Ado in this
video I want to explain to you what
actually happens inside your muscles and
the rest of your body in response to
training and we're going to go a little
bit deeper than your typical explanation
we're going to look at what we do know
what we don't know and we're going to
try and apply this in a practical Manner
and you might be surprised at just what
kind of gains you can unlock as a result
it's not an exaggeration to say that
this might actually be one of my most
important videos today 8.
so the most common explanation you hear
for how hypertrophy and strength gains
work is through muscle damage also
sometimes called myofibular hypertrophy
basically we're told that as we train as
we stretch and place load on the muscle
over time they get damaged we create
micro tears and it's the process of
healing these that leads to muscle
growth in fact hold on one second
[Music]
so inside your muscles you have lots of
muscle fibers these are made up of
something called sarcomeres and these in
turn contain the actin and myosin
contractile proteins and these
essentially kind of move across each
other by a chemical reaction in order to
lengthen and shorten the sarcomeres and
then at the upper level beyond that the
muscle fibers and beyond that your whole
muscle and these lengthen and shorten
and over time this can lead to muscle
damage especially if you place a lot of
pressure on it I like to imagine these
as working almost telescopically with
the actin and the myosin moving within
one another and if you look at how this
works it's not a Perfect Analogy but
it's kind of similar so over time as
these muscle fibers are Contracting and
extending
they basically start to become a little
bit damaged imagine elastic band and
it's repeatedly being stretched
over time it's going to start to fray
and we don't want it to snap that would
be a muscle tear
but we just want it to get a little bit
frayed
in Rush inflammatory cytokines just they
would do for any injury and this Begins
the repair process this is why taking
anti-inflammatory painkillers to combat
soreness following a workout Dons is a
big No-No and can actually prevent
muscle growth this information is what
stimulates the nearby satellite cells to
fuse with the muscle fibers and add more
myonuclei triggering further protein
synthesis
we don't actually create new muscle
fibers through this process or at least
we don't think we do that's something
called muscle hypoplasia and we're not
sure whether or not that can actually
occur in humans there's some evidence to
suggest it can but it's certainly more
rare instead what we're doing is
increasing the sarcomeres which
increases the thickness of the fibers
what's really interesting is that the
concentric portion of the movement
actually increases
sarcomere is in parallel in other words
side by side
whereas The Eccentric portion of
movement the lengthening phase of the
movement that actually increases
sarcomere's in sequence meaning end to
end
again there's just so much going on here
that we rarely hear about
and that we don't fully understand
nuclei are like the nerve sensors of the
cells and they contain copies of our DNA
the genetic code necessary to produce
proteins and send them to the right
places for that specific cell so think
of nuclei like little bubbles containing
the blueprints for building the cell
itself they send out the instructions to
build proteins that allow you to create
more muscle mass so this is where right
away a lot of explanations only go to
the surface level so it's all good and
well to say that you add more DNA in my
nuclei and this builds more muscle but
how is it and why is it that more nuclei
mean more muscle and is this the same
for everyone well to understand this we
must understand our DNA so DNA basically
encodes the creation of proteins it
tells the body which proteins to make
whether those are the kinds of proteins
that are useful for fast Rich muscle
fiber or slow twitch muscle fiber this
DNA is identical whether it's found in
the body and it's Unique to you however
what you can do is you can change the
expression of that DNA thanks to
something called Gene transcription or
epigenetics basically the DNA Remains
the Same but some specific parts of it I
turned either on or off and this changes
how it behaves and therefore allows your
body to create more or less of certain
proteins in other words you have this
set blueprint but you're essentially
scribbling out and adding to it in order
to change the way it behaves so the best
way to think about this is like drawing
lots of letters on a board and then
Crossing out different letters in order
to spell different words the selection
of letters is the same in every cell but
which ones you cross out and which ones
are active is different depending on the
type of cell cat and the good news is
that this can also change in response to
our lifestyles and our training so when
you train hard and your body receives
signals to create more muscle this is
due to Gene transcription everything
from our diet to our thoughts can alter
gene expression we may not be able to
change our genetic code but we can
massively change the way it impacts on
our bodies so for example someone with
the ACT N3 Gene will encode more Alpha
actin in three a protein that's
expressed more in fast type 2 muscle
fiber thus we tend to see this variant
more commonly in power-based app
athletes and sprinters for example
however there's some evidence to suggest
that supplementing with pique oil can
actually result in Altered gene
expression thus increasing the
transcription for Alpha actinine three
this is the burgeoning field of
nutrigenomics by the way likewise
plyometric training can have a similar
impact just as an aside then people who
say that you can't train to increase
explosiveness that's very much not the
case you can be more or less genetically
predisposed towards explosiveness but
you do have at least some degree of
control beyond that but myofibular
hypertrophy is just one kind of
hypertrophy the other more common
explanation for hypertrophy you might
have heard of is sarcoplasmic
hypertrophy and this can be likened to
muscle swelling so think of your muscle
cell which in this case is going to be
represented by a balloon it's full of
all kinds of stuff see how easily I can
get this over here
all right
glycogen
sarcoplasmic reticulum which is a kind
of storage unit
for calcium
triglycerides t-tubules mitochondria of
course
and of course the fluid sarcoplasm
all these things can increase and as
they do
they cause the muscle to swell and
mitochondria played by jelly beans
also standing for tea tubules ah
goodness
enough
pop that in there
feels sort of erotic
need more sarcoplasm
and then you have a bigger muscle
through a separate mechanism than muscle
damage this tends to be the result of
higher rep range training bodybuilding
style training some people say it's like
fake muscle that the muscles are swollen
they're not actually stronger this is
inaccurate not only is there no such
thing as a fake muscle unless you're
going to be using something like Synthol
but at the same time this actually
increases muscle endurance to a large
extent because you're supplying your
muscle with more things you need to
carry on going and that's very important
for your strength and your performance
across the board
these higher rep ranges and continuous
time of tension flood the muscles with
metabolic products and this has other
effects too we all know for example that
hormones play a role in muscle mass
anabolic hormones such as testosterone
growth hormone Etc encourage protein
synthesis through channels such as the
mtor pathway this is released in
response to the heightened presence of
energy nutrients and protein that leads
to increases in igf-1 and other hormones
that produce testosterone in other words
the body builds muscle when it's well
fed and this interacts with our training
if you train and you're well fed you're
going to have a different result than if
you train and you're not longer
bodybuilding style sets can accelerate
this effect that's because a longer set
encourages the buildup of waste products
such as lactic acid via glycolysis
lactate can be used as an additional
fuel it also draws water into the
muscles to increase muscle swelling
which may act as another stimulus for
growth and protein synthesis and best of
all it stimulates the production of
testosterone via the lading cells
lactate also appears to be necessary for
growth hormone production
differences in diet hormone production
and even the presence of Androgen
receptors can all Impact how profound
the effect will be for a given
individual this as far as we know is why
metabolic stress leads to muscle growth
but there's another aspect to consider
as well and that's blood supply
so over time this Demand on the muscle
can even increase blood flow through a
process called angiogenesis we actually
increase the number of blood vessels
supplying the muscle this allows more of
those metabolites to enter the muscle
where they're needed and likewise to
shuttle away waste products improved
blood supply is another great benefit of
high volume training then but the
benefits go far deeper still for example
blood supply is crucial for another type
of hypertrophy that gets a lot less
attention that's connective tissue
hypertrophy
to ensure tendons ligaments and even the
fascia that surrounds the muscle can
also increase in strength again this is
something that just gets overlooked when
talking about growing muscle growing the
tendons growing the connective tissue is
just as important
but tendons have a lower blood supply as
compared to muscle something I talked
about in a very recent video they're
slower to respond to training whereas
muscle growth can occur after just eight
days of lifting for a noob they can take
around two months for the same to occur
in the tendon on the plus side atrophy
takes longer in connective tissue as
well
connective tissue hypertrophy also
refers to fascia and fascia is this kind
of culling film wrap that surrounds the
muscle as well as the organs and things
and this not only helps to hold things
in place it even has its own motor units
and proprioceptors meaning it can
contribute to not only your sense of
self and space But even Force production
and just like Muscle fascia can actually
strengthen in response to tension and
training in response to these pressure
signals fibroblast cells actually lay
down new collagen and collagenase
actually making that part of the fascia
stronger and thereby able to better
transmit Force
but you see the fascia doesn't just
surround the outside of the muscle
tissue it also actually enters and
protrudes into the muscles it then
segments the muscles into bundles of
muscle fibers
called fascicles and each of these are
then wrapped in a separate sheet of
fascia called the epimysium
this whole video is really just an
excuse for me to eat stuff
so yeah it's kind of like an orange in
case you didn't get the metaphor
separated into different segments by a
kind of cling film wrap the interesting
thing is that muscle is actually made up
of 20 connective tissue so the fact that
we can train and thicken and strengthen
the connective tissue means that this is
an important Avenue from improving our
strength and growing muscles and it may
actually connect disparate muscles and
help us to strengthen specific
coordinations of muscle exertion
foreign
[Music]
aiding with communication and
synchronicity between muscles to
understand tensegrity we could once
again
use these elastic bands I'm getting my
money's worth
so here of course the elastic band
represents the fascia and if you think
of it pulled taut then if you ping on
one end
take a look here
if we ping on one end
and that signal travels all the way down
the elastic band
to whatever it's hooked on at the end
there if however the elastic band is
loose like so and we just move it well
then here you're going to be able to
sense that something's going on but
you're not going to be able to feel
you know the precise rhythm
exactly the full signal
then there's more increased blood supply
to the muscle may also increase my
nuclei and satellite cells studies show
a correlation between capillarization
and a muscle satellite cell
proliferation supplementing with
creatine also seems to increase
satellite cells as does increasing
testosterone and training for longer
sessions but we're missing the third
major mechanism for muscle growth that
being mechanical tension and this one's
simple loading a ton of weight onto the
muscles will trigger muscle growth again
the question here is why does mechanical
tension lead to muscle growth what's
actually going on here well it turns out
to do with meccanoreceptors
mechanoreceptors are sensors in your
body that provide you with
proprioceptive feedback to tell you
things like how hard you're Contracting
the muscle or how much stress is under
so I'm able to weigh this protein bar
with my arm because I've got
mechanoreceptors built in that way it's
great enough actually triggers protein
synthesis all on its own even in the
absence of other signals such as hormone
changes or muscle damage and what does
this process actually looked like well
there are actually lots of different
meccano receptors and there are likely
some that we haven't even yet discovered
one candidate for example is the lipid
bilayer this is made from lipid
molecules located within the cell
membrane it's thought that when the cell
is under pressure this could cause them
to get ruptured thereby triggering a
Cascade of events that lead to protein
synthesis
as though all this wasn't already
complicated enough there's also the
different types of muscle fiber to
consider we've already seen them briefly
in this discussion you have your type 1
type 2A and type 2x although in truth
it's more like a spectrum slow type 1
muscle fiber contains more mitochondria
for energy efficient movement type 2 or
fast twitch fiber conversely contains
more atpas which is an enzyme that
catalyzes ATP from ADP type 2 muscle
fiber actually appears thicker but it's
also key to note that fast twitch fibers
produce more lactate versus slow twitch
and we haven't even considered the role
of the brain yet as I've said many times
on this channel you can have the biggest
muscles in the world and you won't
necessarily be very strong that's
because you also need to be able to send
the relevant signals that tell the
muscle to contract this is why someone
physically smaller than you may have a
far more impressive power clean they've
rehearsed the movement muscle fibers are
bundled into groups called motor units
each motor unit is innovated or
triggered by a different nerve which is
connected to the motor cortex the brain
area serves as a map of the body and
activity in each neuron here can trigger
the activation of a specific motor unit
the bicep for example contains roughly
774 motor units corresponding to 774
motor units in the motor cortex
no one can activate all the motor units
in a given muscle at once so there's a
lot of strength that you leave on the
table in accordance with henneman's size
principle we always recruit the smallest
motor units first which also will be
comprised of slow twitch fiber I refer
you back to my recent demonstration of
this with the ball bearings if you have
ball bearings of different sizes and you
blow lightly you can move only the small
ball bearings but to move the big ones
you'll need to blow stronger that will
move the small ones and the big ones
this is how you can get stronger on a
given lift without necessarily adding
any muscle at all
felt like a complete knob filming some
of this and it's raining and I didn't
want to be a litter bug so at one point
I was carrying around wet spat out
ibuprofen right now I've got wet jelly
beans in my camera bag but I was just
trying to find the interesting ways to
convey what would otherwise be quite a
dry topic so I hope this has helped to
make it a little bit wetter for you the
main takeaway from all this is that
building muscle and gaining strength are
not simple they're in fact highly
complex with many different aspects all
playing together off of one another you
can't boil this down to a few simple
things different things are going to
work better or worse for different
people depending on genetics and other
factors what's more is that there's just
so much we don't even know about yet so
much yet to be discovered there are
probably chemicals and processes some of
this stuff we're only just learning now
Andrew Tracy who I follow on Instagram
describe this process as being more akin
to Alchemy than science it's not a
precise art it's more like a dark magic
and therefore we have to just follow
what we feel is working for us but to me
I think an obvious takeaway from this is
that we should be combining different
training methods as I always say we know
that eccentric training builds soccer
mirrors in sequence and concentric build
sarcomeres in parallel then of course it
makes sense to place emphasis on both to
maximize your potential you're just
interested in building max strength as a
power lifter it still makes sense for
you to use pump training if we know that
fast twitch muscle fiber is bigger and
potentially more powerful than slightly
twitch we also know that plyometric
training which increases fast twitch
muscle fiber won't necessarily increase
muscle strength or size then doesn't
make sense to spend some time increasing
your ratio of fast twitch fiber and then
follow that out with training that will
make the most of that fast switch fiber
and I think we can start to even see a
glimmer of an optimal order here
potentially which is something I'm going
to be exploring a lot more in future and
it's something I've actually been doing
in my programs for the longest time now
if you want a training program that does
combine lots of different training
Styles in order to maximize your results
then you might be interested in my ebook
and training program super functional
training 2.0 that includes High rep work
it includes Mobility work it includes
heavy weights and skills practice so
yeah you should get compounding results
from that it's an 80 plus page ebook
with over two hours of instructional
video and I'll leave a link to that in
the description down below either way
guys thank you so much for watching and
I'll see you next time
bye for now
so building muscle is complicated but
you know what's not complicated building
a website at least not when you use
Squarespace Squarespace is today's
sponsor and it's a powerful online
platform for developing modern
attractive and professional websites
with no code necessary so this way you
can turn your passion into a business
and with Squarespace you can build any
kind of website you need there is no
limit to the number of tools available
you have gated members only content for
easy Revenue Generation member
management inbuilt email Communications
audience insights all in a single easy
to use platform
there's a fully integrated commenting
system with threaded comments replies
and likes powerful blogging tools for
sharing content categorizing posts
scheduling publishing and more and
social media integration to display
posts from your social profiles directly
on your website or to push social media
content automatically there's a
comprehensive Suite of e-commerce
capabilities and you can expand on any
of these things by adding third-party
extensions leveling the playing field in
this way by giving everyone the tools
they need to create professional and
beautiful looking websites is a course
that I truly believe in it's why I'm
really proud to have Squarespace as a
sponsor and when you're ready to launch
buy new viewers can get 10 off the
purchase of their first website or
domain by going to squarespace.com
forward slash the bioneer today
thanks once again to Squarespace for
supporting this Channel and thanks to
you guys for watching through to the end
bye for now